foreign
[Music]
thank you everybody for tuning in
um so I'm very excited to be here my
name is Alex Muir and I'm uh super
excited to tell you about the work that
our group uh here at uchicago has been
doing to look at the
different nutritional and metabolic
barriers to tumor immunity that occur in
pancreatic cancer
um so to jump into it I'm going to talk
about the cancer immunity cycle which
probably doesn't need that much of
introduction here for this particular
symposium
but just to say that this is the the way
by which cancer cells release new
antigens and these new antigens can then
be presented to T cells and T cells can
then recognize those antigens infiltrate
into tumors
um
recognize cancer cells that Express
those antigens and kill them and lead to
the continuation of this cycle
and obviously this pathway
um and cycle is is impaired by many
different cancers to enable their
progression and growth
but I'm going to talk about the ways in
particular this that we've been learning
that this cycle has been impaired in
pancreatic cancer
and this pathway and Immunity cycle of
course has been uh
targeted by a number of different
approaches to rejuvenate the cycle to
overcome these barriers to lead to uh a
lot of durable tumor aggressions and
treatment in a number of different
malignancies and of course ctla4 and pd1
based therapies for targeting priming
and activation and killing of cancer
cells have proven incredibly useful
therapeutic Tools in a number of
different malignancies but unfortunately
in pancreatic cancer
as has been highlighted by Florencia
McAllister in this really nice review
down in the bottom right hand corner
these current clinically used approaches
for boosting and rejuvenating the
anti-tumor immunity cycle have not
really had very much efficacy in
pancreatic ductal abdominal carcinoma or
PDX
this has led to a lot of interest in
searching in the field to understand why
these current immunotherapy therapedic
approaches don't work and this is like
kind of this question of a number of
groups in pancreatic cancer field trying
to understand where this immunity cycle
is being broken
and pancreatic cancer and if we can
identify these critical barriers to the
immunity cycle and pancreatic cancer can
we clinically intervene and improve
anti-tumor immunity and immune
immunotherapeutic outcomes in this
disease
and so in the last few years there's
been a lot of real awesome tremendous
work that has identified a number of
different places in which pancreatic
cancers stall this immunity cycle and so
it's been great work from David
dinardo's lab on the left hand side here
showing that there's a profound defect
in dendritic cells and cancer antigen
presentation in pancreatic tumors and
that can stall out this cycle
there's been great work from shukong
zang's Lab showing how different uh cell
types and pancreatic tumors can prevent
infiltration and trafficking of T cells
into the tumor so the T cells never show
up to the tumors to control to kill the
cancer cells and control these tumors in
the first place and then there's also
been great work for kimmelman's lab and
rushika pereira's group
that have highlighted how T cells our
cancer cells can use autophagy to down
regulate their MHC molecules and and
slow their slow their
[Music]
uh signaling and slow their presentation
of antigen to T cells and and thus kind
of trick the immune system in this way
as well
so these are all awesome studies that
have highlighted a number of different
ways in which this pathway has been
broken
um in ways that we can intervene to
improve immunity and pancreas cancer but
I want to talk about one study in
particular that I think is really
highlighting
um
that even if we're able to kind of
bypass this cycle completely that
there's still some barriers to
anti-tumor immunity and pancreas cancer
and this comes from work from Sunil
hingarani's lab and Phil Greenberg's Lab
at uh Fred Hutch
or they asked what happens can we use
adoptive T Cell therapies to control
pancreatic tumors
and a quick primer on adoptive T cell
therapy and this is where T cells are
isolated from autologous T cells from
patients or from donor mice and these T
cells can then be
um transduced with T cell receptors or
chimeric antigen receptors which on the
right here the cars are synthetic
receptors that bind to surface antigens
on cancer cells or the transgenic TCR
approach uses native tcrs that can
recognize tumor antigen that's being
presented by MHC and then these two
cells are stimulated in acidics Vivo and
then they're reinfused back into the
patient where they can go to the tumors
and Target the cancer cells in and
hopefully eliminate them
and so these groups at the hutch what
they did was they identified the tumor
antigen mesotheelin over here on the
left in red which is expressed in nearly
all cancer cells and panins precursor
lesions primary PDA or pedact tumors as
well as in metastases
and these groups developed a
TCR that recognizes this TCR 1045 over
here on the right that recognizes this
mesothel and one is presented on MHC and
they also developed a TCR gag which is a
dummy TCR that doesn't recognize antigen
and when you transfuse mice with these
TCR engineered T cells into tumor
bearing mice as you can see they're able
to infiltrate the tumor quite readily
much more so than the the T cells the
dummy T cells and these T cells are able
to cause a significant amount of cancer
cell apoptosis in these tumors
and so the T cells are able to kind of
bypass a lot of these barriers to tumor
immunity and the tumor immunity cycle
that we talked about and go straight to
the tumors and start acting on them
unfortunately these tumors don't lead to
actually quite excitingly these uh this
kind of adoptive T Cell Therapy is able
to extend the lifespan of these animals
as shown here in these survival curves
compared to tumor bearing animals that
just are getting the TCR control T cells
Infuse but unfortunately there's not
durable responses to these even multiple
infusions of these TCR engineered T
cells all of the mice eventually do
succumb to these disease to this disease
and have disease progression and so why
aren't these T cells even when many many
of them are being infused
repeatedly weren't able to eliminate and
durably control these tumors
and so one piece of evidence for why
this might be occurring why there's this
kind of limitation to this approach is
down here in the right
and basically uh as soon as T cells hit
the microenvironment to these pancreatic
tumors they become profoundly
dysfunctional and they're not able to
exhibit their effector functions and so
these are T cells that are isolated
either from the spleen or from the the
pancreatic tumor microenvironment and if
you take these two cells xvivo
re-stimulate them if the T cells are
coming from the healthy spleen when you
restimulate them they're able to produce
cytokines tnf alkaline interferon gamma
in response to this re-stimulation
in contrast the T cells that are coming
from the tumor are profoundly deficient
in their ability to
produce these effector cytokines in
response to restimulation and
interestingly it doesn't matter if
you're a T Cell that's recognizing the
mesothel and antigen or if you're a T
Cell that's not recognizing any antigen
at all the microenvironment is
suppressive to the T cells regardless of
repeated antigens exposure
and so we think this is telling us
is going back to our tumor immunity
cycle here that a really profound and
important block to tumor immunity is
coming from the tumor microenvironment
that if your T Cell just being in that
micro environment is going to block your
ability to be an effector T cell and to
produce those molecules that allow you
to kill cancer cells and this is
occurring even without antigen
stimulation there's something about this
microenvironment that's inhibiting T
cell function
and so this really LED our group to ask
uh what about it what about the tumor
microenvironment is inhibitory to T cell
function what is in their environment
that's so suppressive add to these
anti-cancer immune cells
and so one possibility that really
caught our attention is there's been a
lot of work recently in the field that
in response to immunological signaling
so signaling through the T Cell receptor
co-stimulatory Pathways or other
cytokines that as this leads to profound
metabolic reprogramming in these cells
and I don't want to dive into all the
details of this diagram here just to say
that
there's a lot of metabolic reprogramming
that's happening kind of under the hood
of these T cells in response to this
stimulation and that metabolic
reprogramming that happens is super
critical for the ability of those cells
to gain those effector functions
and what this means is
let me go over to the right of this
diagram
that because these micro because these
metabolic changes are so critical to the
acquisition of T Cell effector functions
that that means the local nutrient
availability can actually be a really
important regulator of the metabolism
that happens Downstream in these T cells
and thus can be a critical regulator
whether or not the T cells can obtain
these effector functions and so levels
of different amino acids such as leucine
glutamine or carbon sources such as
glucose is shown on these diagrams as
well as other nutrients such as trace
minerals all of these things have been
shown to be really important Regulators
of whether or not T cells are able to
gain their effector functions even when
they're when they're seeing these kind
of immunological cues
and so we thought that this kind of uh
the kind of nutrient regulation of
whether or not a T Cell becomes
effective or not could be potentially
really important in pancreatic tumors
because one thing we know about pancreas
tumors is in contrast to healthy tissues
which have well organized vasculature
I'm over here on the right which leaves
these tissues really well perfused and
in the parenchym of these tissues the
nutrient availability is basically
roughly in equilibrium with the
circulation in pancreas tumors in
contrast
um they have really abnormal uh and poor
vasculature there's excellent work from
Dave tuberson and Ken Oliver I can
estimate that about only 25 of the blood
vessels in these tumors are actually
able to transport anything at any given
time and so these tumors are really
hypoperfused and this could lead to your
really abnormal levels of nutrients in
this microenvironment which could feed
back into the inability of these T cells
to respond to immunological cues in
these Pedic tumors
and so we wanted to ask
um precisely this question could
abnormal nutrient levels in the pdac tme
tumor microenvironment could this be
impairing T cell function in this
disease and contributing to this
exhaustion and then dysfunctional
phenotype that we see
and so to ask this question our group
has developed techniques where we can
isolate interstitial fluid this is the
local perfusate
of the tumor microenvironment from
different Mouse models of pancreas
cancer and then we can and we've
developed quantitative metabolite
profiling pipelines where we can measure
not just relative levels of metabolites
in these interstitial fluid samples
though we can measure the exact
concentration of about 180 major
vitamins nutrients and signaling
molecules and these microenvironmental
samples
what I'm showing here on the right is
when we take a look at
metabolite concentrations and an
unsupervised analysis of plasma samples
from tumor bearing mice versus these
microenvironmental interstitial fluid
samples you can see that the tip samples
um a tumor interstitial fluid samples
are clustering apart and away from the
plasma
sample so there really is a unique
nutrient milieu or metabolic milieu in
these pdac tumors
and so what are the individual
metabolites that are driving this kind
of global metabolic difference
abnormal difference in these pancreas
tumors
and so I'm showing here is a volcano
plot of metabolites that are enriched in
interstitial fluid from pediac tumors on
the right are depleted on the left
um and each one of these dots is an
individual metabolite and there's a few
things that I really want to highlight
and the first one is
normally when we think about the tumor
microenvironment I think kind of our gut
instinct is that it's going to be a
nutrient desert right there's poor
perfusion so there's poor nutrient
delivery so mostly there's going to be
metabolites that are depleted in the
microenvironment that's actually not
what we see and there's actually more
metabolites that are enriched in the
interstitial fluid of these pancreas
tumors and this includes a lot of
metabolites that could have really
profound roles on Cell physiology
there's neurotransmitters like Gaba
amino acids like glutamate and glycine
that are accumulating in the
microenvironment as well as molecules
like phosphoethanol Amina Kennedy
pathway intermediate which I'm going to
talk about
um in a bit so I think that's one really
important thing is to conceptualize the
microenvironment of tumors is not just
being depleted of things but also
accumulating metabolites as well
there's a lot of metabolites that also
surprised us which don't really change
between the plasma and the interstitial
fluid our kind of picture going into
this study was that cancer cells are
going to be the primary controller of
what nutrients are in the tumor
microenvironment and so the things that
they consume or release are going to be
the things that are the most depleted or
enriched in the tumor microenvironment
so things like glucose lactate and
glutamine these would be the things that
would be most depleted or enriched in
the microenvironment
this is not actually what we see we
don't really see a significant decrease
in glutamine in these Pedic tumors there
is a decrease in glucose but it's not
amongst the most depleted metabolites
and we don't actually don't see an
increase in lactate as well and so we
really are starting to wonder if our
kind of hypothesis that
some cancer cells are controlling the
nutrient microenvironment of tumors if
perhaps that might not be entirely true
in every tumor type
but there are some metabolites that are
strikingly depleted from the
interstitial uh environment of these
Pedic tumors and this includes a number
of amino acids such as Arginine cystine
and tryptophan and these are all amino
acids that we know as suppressive
myeloid cells work to deplete from
tumors
and so that's one thing we're starting
to consider is that perhaps the
metabolic milieu of these tumors is not
only responding to what the cancer cells
are doing but are really heavily
influenced by what infiltrating myeloid
cells are metabolically doing and we
also do see some metabolites like
pyruvate which is really critical for
cells to adapt to hypoxic States also
being depleted in the microenvironment
these tumors are quite hypoxic and so
we're also starting to consider the
hypothesis that perhaps tumor hypoxia is
an important
um
component driving some of these
metabolic changes in the tumor
microenvironment
all right so we have kind of a parts
list now we know what metabolites are
enriched or depleted in the tumor
microenvironment we know what
concentrations there are how can we ask
if these metabolic abnormalities in
these Pedic tumors are contributing to
the T cell function that we see in Vivo
and so to ask this question
what we've done is we've took our
quantitative measurements of nutrients
in the tumor microenvironment we use
this to develop a cell culture
formulation that we call tiffum for
tumor interstitial fluid medium and this
contains 115 polar metabolites at the
exact concentrations that we measured in
these microenvironmental isolates and to
make the complete media we add these
metabolites to dialyzed fps to provide
them the to provide cells the protein
and growth factors they need for for
growth
and rpmi and organic salt solution and
so this allows us to have a medium which
is basically the same as our kind of
standard T Cell culture or PMI
but just with different concentrations
of metabolites so we can take this media
formulation
put this on T cells in comparison to
rpmi and just ask how does changing the
metabolite concentrations to make them
physiological how does this change T
cell function in Behavior
and so we've been working on this
project as a part of a long-standing
really productive collaboration with
Greg delgoff at the University of
Pittsburgh and an extremely talented
student in this group Jeremy Wang and so
in collaboration with Greg's group
uh we did the following experiment where
we took uh ot1 T cells and activated
them with um peptide
and then expanded these T cells either
in rpmi or for different periods of time
in interstitial fluid medium and then
put these cells all back into rpmi and
ask what happens when we restimulate
these cells
um by cross-linking how do they how does
their expansion potential change and how
does their functional profile change
and the first thing we found is that as
cells spend increasing amount of time in
these microenvironmental nutrients
their ability to expand when we
stimulated decreases so you can see here
cells in our PMI expand quite robustly
but as cells spend increasing amount of
time in interstitial fluid medium their
expansion potential goes down
in addition to this defect and expansion
the T cells as they spend more time in
interstitial fluid medium they lose more
and more effective functions they're
less able to produce tnf and interferon
as well as granzyme and they
increasingly have higher levels of cell
surface pd1
a marker of exhaustion and dysfunction
um and so uh our kind of key take home
is if we isolate the interstitial
um a kind of microenvironmental nutrient
stress that on its own is sufficient to
contribute to the T Cell dysfunction and
so we uh is sufficient to cause T cells
dysfunction so we do think that this
kind of nutritional abnormalities in the
tumor Market environment are a key
contributor to the
dysfunctional phenotype that we see of T
cells that wind up in these tumors
and we wanted to ask now using this
tiffum platform can we identify the
metabolites that are depleted or
enriched that are responsible for these
defects that we see in both T Cell
expansion and T cell function
and so the first thing I'm going to talk
about is we looked at metaboloids that
were depleted in the interstitial fluid
medium and asked if those depleted
metabolites are contributing to
expansion or these function defects that
we observed
and so going back to our atlas of
interstitial fluid metabolites we know
exactly which nutrients are depleted
um relative to plasma and rpmi and so we
can take those metabolites and do the
same experiment we have T cells that are
expanded in rpmi it's our positive
control expanded into foam is our
negative control and then we can add
back uh
those metabolites that are depleted in
tiffum to rpmi concentrations and
re-stimulate the cells and ask if we add
those nutrients back does that improve
T-cell expansion or T cell function
and so what I'm showing here is when we
look at T Cell expansion you can see in
the black trace the cells in rpmi expand
quite well and Tiff media for five days
they lose their ability to expand and if
we add back in green one amino acid in
particular this depleted Arginine it's
basically able to rescue
the ability of these two cells to expand
and this is consistent with a really
great work from Roger Geiger who's shown
that are just a critical nutrient for T
cell growth and this is depleted in our
interstitial fluid medium and it's
totally consistent with that if we add
the Arginine back these T cells regain
their expansion potential there's also
great work from
costociotis and Marina pasca
demagliano's lab that have identified
low levels of arginine in Pedic tumors
is limiting the number of acetate
effector cells that are in this
microenvironment so we think that we are
this identification of arginine is as
being Limited in the tumor
microenvironment is quite relevant at T
Cell
dysfunction in in this compartment
um interestingly we found when we add
Arginine back this does rescue T Cell
expansion but it doesn't seem to
completely rescue T cell function so if
we look at cytokine production when
arginine is added back this isn't
rescued to rpmi levels
um it's basically the same as what was
happening in media we do see a partial
Rescue of grand Zone production but not
really a rescue of
pd1 cell surface expression and a
partial Rescue of pd1 surface expression
as well
and so this is kind of telling us that
the depleted metabolites in an
interstitial fluid medium they do limit
T Cell expansion and to a certain extent
their function but there has to be
something else that's going on in this
media that's um also inhibiting the
vector function of T cells and so what
we did was we asked which of the
metabolites that are enriched in the
interstitial fluid medium can any of
these be affecting a T cell effector
function the pond restimulation
and so again we can go back to our atlas
of which metabolites are enriched in the
interstitial fluid and we can set up the
experiments again where we expand T
cells
in our pmias our positive control
interstitial fluid medium is there
negative control or an rpmi where we're
adding back these individual metabolites
at the concentrations that are in Tiff
media and then re-stimulate these cells
and then ask how does their Vector
function change
and so what I'm showing here is looking
at tnf and interferon gamma production
and rpmi or rpmi supplemented with all
these metabolites that are at increased
concentration in the micro environment
or in purple when all of these
metabolites have been mixed together
and what we found is that when we mix
all of these metabolites that are at
high concentration put this into rpmi
this is able to suppress cytokine
production in these T cells individually
though lactaids glutamate Glycine and G
hap which is a central carbon metabolite
none of these metabolites are able to
on their own impact a cytokine
production but this Kennedy pathway
intermediate which I alluded to before
phosphorth and olamide has almost the
same degree of suppressive ability as
the whole mixed pool of these
metabolites
and we found on its own phosphorylamine
supplementation into rpmi is able to be
just as suppressive of cytokine
production is interstitial fluid medium
and
we also found if we take tiffum
replenish this medium with Arginine and
remove the phosphorthanolamine this is
able to lead to about a 50 Rescue of
cytokine production in T cells upon
restimulation and so we do think that we
have identified well not all of the
metabolites and nutritional conditions
and Tiff media that are affecting T cell
function we have found a couple Arginine
phosphothanolamine that are particularly
important
we have a lot of information about how
Arginine affects T cell function but we
know relatively little about how
phospho-ethanolamine could be regulating
T cells and so we wanted to understand
how does elevated levels of
phospho-ethanolamine that were seen in
these tumor micro environments how is
that affecting and impairing T cell
function
and so what is fossil ethanolamine over
here on the left I'm showing the Kennedy
pathway of which phosphorylamine is a
component
this is a pathway by which cells can
make the membrane lipid phosphatidyl
ethanolamine from ethanolamine is a
precursor and so ethanolamine can be
converted by ethanol and kinase to
phosphoethanolamine CDP ethanolamine
before this is
um
now with the combination of dinosaur
glycerol used to make phosphatidyl
ethanolamine what we found is any of the
Kennedy pathway intermediates when we
add these to T cells they're all able to
suppress cytokine production and so we
wanted to know what is it about really
ramping up the Kennedy pathway
that is causing
impairing T cell function
and so we entertained a number and
tested a number of different hypotheses
the one I'm going to talk about now
um
it's the one that we think is going on
and this is actually because the Kennedy
pathway actually shares some really
important metabolic overlap with T cell
signaling so the Kennedy pathway when
it's upregulated it's consuming a lot of
diesel glycerol which diasochlycerol is
a really important component of T cell
signaling and so when T cells and when
the TCR is engaged T cells produce a lot
of diesel glycerol
in response to the stimulation and this
diacylglycerol is a really important
second messenger that activates protein
kinase C which is critical for inducing
the gene transcription programs that are
required for gaining activation and
effector function and so what we wanted
to know is if we are if possible at the
nolanine in the micro environments is
ramping up the Kennedy pathway in these
T cells and limiting to isochlycerol for
T cell signaling
and so to test this what we found is if
we look at diacyl cholesterol levels in
T cells
um by flow cytometry when we add phospho
ethanolamine to cells and this does
decrease the amount of
dicyclitis available in these T cells
and so we wanted to know is this
reduction in disulglycerol that's coming
from
phospho-ethanolamine upregulation of the
Kennedy pathway is this what's actually
causing effector cell dysfunction
um
and so to test this we asked if we have
T cells and we culture them in
phosphorthanolamine which I'm showing
here on the right that does indeed
suppress their ability to produce
cytokines in response to stimulation
uh if we
exogenously activate pkc using pkc
activators like PMA is that sufficient
to rescue cytokine production in T cells
and you can see here on the right in a
dose dependent manner as we add more PMA
and just activate pkc on the Zone even
in this condition where T cells are have
less ISO cholesterol this is able to
rescue in large part of their cytokine
production and so we do think that this
is the a major pathway by which
phosphoid the nolamine is blocking T
cell function
is by blocking the ability of T cells to
produce disochlycerol and response to
stimulation
and so lastly we wanted to ask
um does this
phospho-ethanolamine inhibition of the
isochlycerol signaling is this something
that actually matters for T Cell
anti-tumor immunity and real tumors
where T cells are going to be seeing all
kinds of different signals and
stimulators phosphoethanolamine if we
modulate that on its own is that going
to be able to affect T cell function and
anti-tuber immunity
and so the first experiment we did was
we set B16 melanoma tumors in mice and
gave them female T cells to Target those
tumors and just looked at dissocular
levels and T cells that ended up in the
tumor or in lymph nodes now what you can
see is in the tills and the tumor
infiltrating lymphocytes they're
substantially less dicylchlycerol um
compared to T cells coming from the
lymph node and so that is consistent
with the local increase in
phosphoethanolamine in these tumor
microenvironments being able to suppress
the isochlycerol levels and signaling in
T cells and then we wanted to ask
if we modulate the tumoral levels of
phospho-ethanolamine is that able to
change diacylcerol signaling T Cell
effector status and tumor control and so
to ask this we generated B16 cells that
overexpressed this enzyme pcyt2 and the
Kennedy pathway which will soak up
phosphoethanolamine by rapidly
converting it to CDP ethanolamine so
this will decrease the tumoral and and
levels of phospho-ethanolamine and we
can then ask what happens to T cells
when we inject them that show up in the
either control environment or this tumor
environment with less
phospho-ethanolamine
and what we find is when we look at T
cells that have that are in these tumors
where there's higher pcyt2 levels they
have less they have much higher levels
of diacyl cholesterol they have higher
production of
uh cytokines and these T cells these
tumors on their own don't have any
difference in tumor size or growth but
when they're challenged with T cells at
female T cells these tumors with less
phosphoid phosphorylamine are more
responsive and have smaller tumors in
response to T Cell Therapy
and so we really do think that
phospho-ethanolamine is a even in the
context of a tumor where T cells are
seeing all these different kinds of
signals this signal if we modulate the
signal that's able to impact T-cell
biology and affect your status
and so I'll stop there and sum up a few
key points from this work and I think
the first thing is is I really want to
highlight is that the pdac tumor
microenvironment is really an important
um
uh limitation on T Cell
on any tumor immunity because it really
does Drive T Cell dysfunction and
impairs the ability of these cells to
actually kill cancer cells
and then by developing this interstitial
fluid medium and making these
measurements of what's in the
microenvironment we've been able to
identify microenvironmental nutrients
stress is really a major driver of that
dysfunction that T cells
exhibit when they show up in these pedac
tumors
and by building this medium this has
also allowed us to really go in and
mechanistically identify which of the
nutrients in the micro environments are
driving this dysfunction and how are
those nutrients driving this
and so we've identified that there are
some metabolites essential metabolites
for T Cell Biology that are depleted in
tumor environments namely Arginine and
that lack of arginine does indeed
contribute to T Cell dysfunction in
particular contributes to their lack of
ability to expand and proliferate in
response to stimulation I think really
importantly the other thing that we've
identified is that it's not just
metabolites that are in a micro
environment this interest starved at
things but there's also many many
metabolites that are accumulating in
this microenvironment and some of these
have really profound suppressive effects
on T cells for example this
phosphorylamine
by up regulating the Kennedy pathway
is able to interact with and decrease
really essential signaling nodes for TCR
engagement and T cell function so I
think that's a really important thing to
think about going forward is the
microenvironment is not just things that
have been decreased decrease in American
environment but there's many metabolites
that are accumulating that can have
really important impacts on immune cell
biology
and we're as we look at different tumors
if we look at them compared to plasma
and fossil ethanoline concentrations in
many different types of tumors from
melanoma to pancreas tumors depressed
cancers we're seeing
um profoundly increased levels of
phospho-ethanolamine kind of across many
different tumor types and so we are
starting to really think about
phospho-ethanolamine as a potentially
pretty potent onco metabolite that's
immunosuppressive that could be
contributing to the inability of the
anti-cancer immunity cycle to control
tumors and so we're very excited to
start to look for ways to
Target and potentially
improve the ability of T cells to
function when they're seeing this
immunosuppressive metabolite
and so I'll stop there and just want to
say a big thank you to everyone in our
group here we are beautiful Lake
Michigan and in particular chufan Kai a
former graduate student in our group who
did all of this AT phosphorylamine and T
Cell work again in very close
collaboration with Greg delgoff and
Jeremy Wang
at University of Pittsburgh a big thank
you to our collaborators at the
Whitehead Institute who helped us
develop all of our metabolomics Pipeline
and our funding sources and I will stop
there and I'm happy to take any
questions and all the questions I'll
respond to you by email so very much
looking forward to add your thoughts